all right so a complicated aircraft will
have a lot of systems these are the
systems from the Canada regional jet I
how well did I fly it
we landed in once at Toronto and I was
doing this and the captain said to me
well it was a young guy he said well you
know nobody nobody was born knowing how
to fly fifty three thousand pound jet
anyway this is the kind of stuff you
have to learn for the big aircraft here
are these systems that we're going to
talk about that you have on a small
aircraft the engine first of all what
are the types you might remember you
know the cool old days you had these big
radial engines and they went up to you
know 3,500 horsepower I think was the
biggest one but your typical world war
ii fighter might have a 2,000 horsepower
radial engine turboprops so we'll get
into this more I have a special lecture
on turbines and multi engine but it's a
jet engine that's hooked into a
propeller and that lets you land on
shorter runways and it's more fuel
efficient in at lower altitudes the
popular examples the Pratt & Whitney pt6
has been around since the 50s a
competitor from the similar era was
designed by Garrett those have typically
slugged it out one of them is a free
turbine so you have the PT six and this
is a GE walther derivative they now call
the GE advanced turboprop so the cold
air comes in it gets burned and the hot
is the hot exhaust gases spin this power
turbine which has a shaft that drives
the compressor and it also goes back
this way
there's there's a second I think one of
them drives the compressor and there's a
second wheel there that it's exposed to
the hot gases and it will drive the
propeller so there's kind of a fluid
coupling there through the air where's
the garrett honey well
product has a direct drive transmission
that's more complicated but also a
little bit more fuel-efficient so those
are the two big designs you get a lot
more reliability with a turboprop if you
need power it's hard to make a piston
engine reliable if it generates a lot of
horsepower the disadvantage is nobody's
really figured out how to make these
things for less than half a million
dollars you know new in a box and the
most popular airframes for the turboprop
for things that you might fly the
beechcraft king air which is twin-engine
and the Pilatus pc-12 which is a single
turbo Jets which the FAA calls them
treble Jets they're really turbo fans
because of the bypass air we'll see that
in the next slide these are one thing to
remember about them is they're normally
aspirated they actually do produce less
and less power as you get up to higher
altitudes which is important for taking
off you know in Colorado on a hot day
you have much lower noise and vibration
maybe not a few Mountain one of them
right over your ear
that's the Cirrus jet which is kind of a
cool simple personal jet they actually
have sort of taken over the market
starting in model airplanes going all
the way up to the Boeing's
and the air buses and the only gap where
turbo jets have not taken over is in
your family airplane right your four
seater your six seater that's where
nobody's figured out how to make a
turbojet that really makes economic
sense or even sense for the range they
tend not to be as efficient at these low
power settings the smaller the turbojet
the less efficient it has been
unfortunately so you wouldn't get the
kind of range that you get out of a
cirrus or assessment if you stuck a jet
engine in there these are more
vulnerable a bird will usually just you
know get Cuisinart admire propeller but
if it goes into the jet engine then you
know it can destroy it
so the single-engine jet well some
single-engine Jets like fighters they
just have an ejection seat the Cirrus
England
jet has a parachute for the whole
aircraft to float yeah all right a
turbojet again this is not really on the
exam but it's just good general
knowledge the the fresh air comes in
here it gets compressed by the
compressor once again that's normal
aspiration so it's just a fixed
compression ratio doesn't get more
extreme like with the turbocharger and a
piston engine at higher altitude notice
this bypass air it's being spun that
blade in the front is really acting like
a propeller here's where the compressed
air gets burned and drives these power
turbines that drive the compressor and
the fan in front so it seems like a
really simple design but there's a
tremendous amount of engineering in the
blades and if anything is fabricated
just slightly wrong you know the whole
thing comes apart and explodes so that's
one reason I think they're you know in
the million dollar range for a typical
business jet engine alright so let's go
back to our world which unfortunately is
going to be the reciprocating piston
engine kind of like in your car the
designs I don't know the fundamentals
may not have changed that much since the
Wright brothers but certainly you know
the designs that in your modern session
or Piper the basic geometry the engine
design that's really all from the 1950s
the good news is that with numerically
controlled machine tools and such
they're much more reliable than they
used to be people you know engine
failure was an everyday event at a busy
Airport in the old days and now you know
I've flown for I don't know 4,000 plus
hours with Pistons and I've never had
any kind of real engine problem the
horizontal opposition supposedly smooth
things out they may ask you about that
i'ma test like the turbojet it's
normally aspirated so the performance
degrades as you go to hot and high
elevations where the air is thinner
we'll talk about that in the performance
calculations you directly drive the
propeller so if the engines spinning at
2500 rpm the propeller spending at 2500
rpm there's no transmission
the coolness the air it's called air
cooled and the air flows over the
cylinders but there's also a lot of oil
circulating which has a significant
cooling function the lowest cost and
simplest airplanes have a carburetor
rather than fuel injection and you'll
get 200 horsepower or less out of hay
well I guess the latest fly combings can
do 215 out of a four cylinder you can
get a little bit fancier a plane like a
Cirrus or the latest Cessnas will have
fuel injection turbo charging sounds
like the ideal thing for an aircraft why
wouldn't you want that for a machine
that goes through airs of all kinds of
different densities it seems like the
ideal thing just make the density back
to sea level at least all the time which
is called term turbo normalization the
problem is that they share an oil system
with the rest of the engines so when the
turbocharger breaks it tends to cause
all the oil to leak out of the engine
and now you have a broken in you know
here what had been a perfectly good
engine with a broken turbocharger
becomes a real emergency so people you
know except out west where you really
need the performance because you are
going up high a lot or you're starting
from high and hot the turbochargers tend
to be unpopular although it's an ideal
engineering solution the more cylinders
also the less vibration so if you have
higher horsepower or if you just wanted
to be smooth like the original SR 20s
came with 6-cylinder 200 horsepower
engines because they wanted to wanted it
to be smoother Rotax is the most popular
engine in the light sport in an
experimental world that's a engine
that's a little bit more like a car
engine it revs pretty high it's got a
water cooling you know radiator with
antifreeze and the transmission gears
the prop down to a lower speed all right
here's your basic engine
so up here in the some wonder head you
have your intake and exhaust valves and
your spark plug down here there's the
crank case and crank shaft here's an
exciting this is kind of an inline four
but you get an idea of the power strokes
people everybody used to know this in
the old days because they were excited
about a car so they had a lot of car
related knowledge and it's basically the
same idea but now in the uber age we
can't take that for granted so you've
got your intake stroke top left and then
the cylinder the piston is pushed back
up to compress the air fuel mixture the
spark plugs ignite notice how there's
two of them here that gives you some
redundancy as well as more uniformity of
combustion which pushes the piston back
down generating the power and then
finally the piston rotates up and pushes
the air out I think this might be called
the Otto cycle I think a German guy
invented this actually a French guy
patented at first but maybe Otto reduced
it to practice first anyway it's a
European invention from the late
18-hundreds and it really hasn't changed
much force four-stroke cycle ok cooling
as I said it's a combination of the air
and the oil circulation the FA wants you
to note with it if you're getting the AB
the engine is going hot again this is
probably not going to happen to you here
at sea level but if you're climbing in
your little airplane you know out of
Wyoming on a hot day you might end up
having to accept a slightly lower climb
rate boost your air speed a little bit
and lower the nose to get more cooling
air the mixture control you don't see
this in cars because they have automatic
systems to adjust the air fuel mixture
and get the right amount of air in there
to course the right amount of fuel in
there too corresponding to the density
of the air but in aviation
you know there's your little mixture
knob where
you can lean out in the mixture the
fuel-air mixture you start out rich when
you're taking off because you're at a
very high power setting and the extra
rich mixture cools the engine if you go
really extreme with this like you test
taxi around for half an hour with the
mixture control at full rich in some
engines you may end up getting lead
fouling on the spark plugs if you're up
cruising and you lean it out too much
and the engines going to get a little
bit rough and some of the temperatures
will go too high on the modern aircraft
you have very sophisticated engine
monitors that tell you all kinds of
information about what the temperatures
are they may help you lean to the
optimum mixture it's kind of if you have
an autopilot it's kind of a good good
way to invest some of your time once
you're in the crews carburetors how do
they work if you fly a Piper or a Cessna
you can say that you have a jet-powered
aircraft because there is a jet in the
carburettor that's letting the
low-pressure air and this venturi pull
little bits of fuel vapor out into the
well I guess that throttle looks pretty
well closed but ideally the throttle
would be kind of open and the air would
be going air fuel mixture would be going
into the some wonders carb icing so
remember lower pressure as the pressure
falls the temperature will also fall so
even if it's not below freezing outside
it can become below freezing in the
middle of the carburetor and therefore
water vapor that has been in the air can
turn into ice and eventually block the
airflow to the engine so they tell you
look well just detect that by loss of
rpm you know you're flying along should
be watching the rpm gauge so obviously
you would notice this and take the
recked action instead of having a
machine that would figure this out and
do it for you
I guess one reason they don't want to
just have carp eat all the on all the
time is that it robs the engine of of
some of its you know last 10 or 15
horsepower or whatever so the carb heat
because it makes the air hotter it's
just like going up to a higher altitude
or going up or flying on a hotter day
the air is going to be thinner and
therefore there are fewer molecules of
the air to combust and you won't get as
much power
question.what generates the carpi that's
a good question
same thing that generates the cabin heat
you basically run the air over the
exhaust system before it goes to the
carburetor before it comes into the
cabin good question yeah so I think
1950s cars you know had some kind of
automatic mechanism for this it was you
know bi-metal valve and I don't know we
the mixture control hasn't been seen in
automotive automobiles for quite a long
time the ignition systems of aircraft is
actually pretty well designed you have
Magneto's you can see them here and here
let me do this you can see them here at
the bottom the left and right Magneto's
are geared into the engine and they
generate their own voltage so basically
you don't need to have a working battery
or working alternator to have a running
engine unlike in a car all you need is
that these one of the Magneto's is still
connected and working properly so it's
totally separate from what you might
think of the aircraft's electrical
system and for further burden see each
magneto is connected to half of the
spark plugs such that if you lose a
magneto you still have one working spark
plug in each cylinder does that make
sense you can see that in this drawing
here where each cylinder is being fed
either from the green or the blue
magneto to one of the two spark plugs
and you can test to see if it runs
smoothly on either Magneto
your ignition switch on the airplane
will have a right mag only switch the
left mag only switch or both mags which
is where you have normal operation but
when you're testing on the ground you'll
typically see if it works on either
Magneto okay
abnormal combustion what can you get you
can get detonation which is the mixture
ignites before the spark ignites or pre
ignition which is a slow burn before the
spark and detonation I think is probably
the one that's more common and it could
be caused by you know improper leaning
aviation fuel basically 100 low lead
which has died blue is all that you're
going to see in the continental US in
the future though so low that means it's
lower and lead than the stuff that they
were making you know in the 1930s or
whatever it's still pretty high Inlet
it's like the super you know it's like
the premium leaded gasoline I think of
the 1970s most engines actually don't
require this it's just that it takes so
long to get anything done in aviation
that they can't put an alternative
certify and get an alternative fuel to
the airports but you know your typical
Cessna or your Robinson r44 with the
carburetor it doesn't need this lead
it's you know in the fuel and then gets
spewed out in the atmosphere it's kind
of a tragedy and it's been made worse by
this ethanol stuff so the government
says you'd have to put ethanol and car
gasoline so you can't just go and take
premium car gas from the gas station and
pour it into your aircraft from a
technical point of view even if it were
legal regulatory wise because the
ethanol will destroy a lot of the fuel
system in the aircraft which wasn't
engineered for it but if you did have
ethanol free there are a few places that
have no gas they get special ethanol
free car gas and
you know the lower performance aircraft
engines will run just fine on there have
been committees you know 20 years is
kind of like the standard unit of time
and aviation so for about 20 years
people have been working on some kind of
certified unleaded gasoline that'll work
with most engines if you see clear fuel
in the sump it usually means the
airplanes been left out in the rain and
some water has gotten in there and you
got to make sure that you drain that out
so there's drain plugs on the bottom of
the wings typically and maybe one near
the bottom of the engine that you can
see if any water has gotten into the
fuel system jet fuel is hazardous to
piston engines the nozzles are designed
so that they're physically incompatible
you shouldn't be able to put jet fuel
into a piston engine occasionally does
happen I know a guy who was flying his
Piper Malibu all around all around the
world and he got some barrels of fuel
delivered to him and he had to like pump
it himself and I don't know for whatever
reason there was jet fuel in there is
the pizza here
yeah well whenever the pizza's here I
think I think we're yeah well well yeah
well we'll take a break as soon as the
pizza shows up all right fix propellers
so your most basic trainer has a regular
propeller that it's angle relative to
the hub never changes there's also in
higher performance aircraft constant
speed propellers where there's an
adjustment mechanism that you can read
about a mechanical collection of Springs
and spinning weights that'll try to keep
the propeller at 1 rpm and that can be a
lot more efficient in different phases
of flight you can see from this that if
you have a constant speed propeller the
efficiency across a huge range of speeds
is roughly constant whereas if you have
a climb prop or a fixed prop or a cruise
prop that it's only working optimally at
certain air speeds all right so if you
have a constant speed propeller you're
now going to have three power lovers
that's the business end of it from a
pilot's point of view you'll have
throttle which is the black one on the
left the blue prop speed control and
then the red mixture the FA they may ask
you about this you know they have this
doctrine it's not really true of all
engines but the idea is that you don't
want like a high power setting and a
really low rpm setting they claim that
that's making the propeller take such
big bytes of the air to keep the low
speed that it's somehow stressing the
engine but again if not every engine
manufacturer agrees with that all right
let's talk about well stirred well
started on flight instruments to our
pizza arrives so this is you know gonna
be your reality I would say some of the
test stuff concerns the steam gauges of
the past that you still at low that you
still see at flight schools and that
there's they're there
some things that we can learn from this
though that we'll get into there are
some advantages but anyway let's start
with this six-pack because actually the
electronic stuff is mostly trying to
replicate what was done during World War
two there's very little in a modern
aircraft that isn't some kind of
upgraded version of what was in the
Boeing b-29 bomber so it's worth kind of
knowing where it came from so you've got
your six-pack you've got your airspeed
indicator on the top left you've got
your attitude indicator or artificial
horizon
you've got your altimeter on the top
right vertical speed coming down around
to the lower right which tells you how
fast you're going up or how fast you're
going down a directional gyro which is
like a stabilized compass showing you
where you're pointed assuming that's
been adjusted properly it has to be
reset to the compass and flight every
now and then aah-ha is our pizza here
you didn't see Eddie
oh no okay and then you have a turn
coordinator which is another backup gyro
that tells you whether you're turning
left or right and also the coordination
that's just a ball we'll get into that
in a little bit but whether the airplane
is kind of pitch yaw improperly Yod all
right so it says electric for a
gyroscope to keep spinning that means
it's being powered by electric what else
could it be powered by and does anybody
know what what else is there besides
electricity that can make this thing
spin
yeah vacuum so in the old days you know
again this is not as common you'd have a
vacuum pump on the engine that would
generate a force to keep these gyro
spinning and those were often failing
which had some pretty bad
I don't know somebody yeah I guess
there's a few Piper warriors yeah that's
a good reason not to take like the most
basic airplane into the clouds because
the idea is that you're supposed to sort
of notice do they have and I guess some
of them have a little warning light when
the vacuum pump fails but you know in
the in the most classic situation you're
supposed to notice it's a pilot in the
clouds that this artificial horizon is
failing and it's inconsistent with this
instrument and then you decide what
should the to to believe generally it's
this one because it's more reliable and
then you continue your flight to the
cloud without the artificial horizon
anyway it's ridiculous obviously so you
know real IFR airplanes these days have
two attitude indicators both powered by
electric and you don't have to sort of
notice the subtle sign of them failing
there's just a big flag that pops up
when they fail you know if they lose
power for some reason for example all
right
the pitot-static system so how do you
know anything about your airspeed
there's a tube somewhere on the airplane
usually hanging out under the wing and
your typical trainer or next to the nose
you see them on jets where the ram air
comes in and the more ram air pressure
there is then the faster you're going
that can be compared to the static
pressure which comes in from a static
port usually on the side of the airplane
it has to be in you know some part of
the airplane where the airflow is you
know suitable for a static port so the
ram air feeds only the airspeed
indicator and the static source has to
feed the altimeter in the vertical speed
you got to read this book there's a
couple questions about what happens if
the pitot tube gets clogged or if the
static port is blocked and taped over
and that makes the instruments read
inaccurately so I read about that for
the test okay
airspeed indicator here's what I was
talking about how in some ways the old
stuff is better so look here's a good
example of
how you get more information out of this
than out of the speed tape on the modern
instrument this gives you all of the
aircraft's performance basically you
don't really need to refer to the manual
to see a lot of important information
well don't fly you know that the speed
tape might only show you from here to
here you know from like 120 knots up to
150 or something but here you're seeing
okay let's not fly faster than about two
hundred and eight knots unless we have
the flaps out
let's not fly slower than about fifty
eight knots and even with the flaps
hanging down we don't want to fly slower
than 55 knots because that's gonna be
where it's gonna stall you know at
certain CG configurations and a gross
weight ok the yellow arc well the yellow
arc is to be avoided unless the air is
smooth so that was actually a great user
interface and because cool Jets have the
speed tape when they make the glass
panels for little airplanes which really
don't need that kind of precision and
speed control they said well let's just
have this thing that you know the jet
pilots have all right how does the
airspeed indicator work
there's brass in there so it's a cool
you know old-school Sherlock Holmes
style brass instrument the ram air is
coming in there's a diaphragm that moves
some levers and eventually the needle
swings again you know you don't don't
have to design one for your test just
have to know that it's gonna respond to
the ram air some of these little symbols
are worth knowing
probably VA is the most important
because it's on the test I believe as
something that's not indicated on the
airspeed indicator that's the
maneuvering speed that's the speed at
which you can do extreme control inputs
and not bend the airplane any faster
than maneuvering speed it's possible
that you could you know yank the yoke
back so hard that you'd bend the wings a
little better overstressed them the
reason it's not indicated on the
airspeed indicator is it varies by
weight
and it's actually higher as something
worth reading about it's higher if the
airplane is heavier it's one of the few
speeds where weight is helpful because
if it's really heavy it's just harder to
get the airplane to perform in some
extreme manner VSO is also worth looking
at that's basically the speed that's
going to determine how fast you land
that's the speed the airplane will stall
and landing configuration so you usually
want to be going at least 20% faster
than that to give yourself a safety
margin okay here's something from the
New England air museum and Bradley
Connecticut another great destination
about half an hour's flight away huge
airport great FBO that will give you a
free car to use while you're there it's
called signature flight support there
anyway so this aircraft I think it's a
p40 from world war ii and it can go up
to 500 miles an hour
all right altimeter this aircraft is at
about 10,000 feet so notice it has this
little triangular needle at one that's
telling you this at 10,000 feet and then
the longer needle is reading in hundreds
so we're at about ten thousand two
hundred and sure enough we can see it
this is indicating you know ten thousand
one hundred eighty so three needles
usually the ones you're gonna deal with
are this one at the top here for
thousands of feet and this one for
hundreds of feet okay
so back in the old days before we
decided to dig up all the coal and the
oil and set it on fire
this was our standard atmosphere and it
was wonderful and it was always 15
degrees at sea level and it was always -
9 or 9 or - for pressure but now we've
ruined it the standard atmosphere is the
basis for a huge number of calculations
the altimeter we're going to look at
this again it has these anti furs that I
guess provide a reference
and some have the difference between
what's in there and what's coming in
will make the needles move that's about
as much as I know not being a mechanical
engineer an important factor though with
all these altimeters as you can set it
to correct it for whatever the
prevailing pressure is locally so that's
what you really need to know as a pilot
that if they tell you the altimeter
setting is three zero five three that
you turn it until you see three two zero
five three in the window it's worth
knowing these altitude definitions the
most important for determining aircraft
performance is going to be density
altitude that's kind of tracks the
actual number of molecules that are in a
given volume of air if you're flying
along you'll be looking at indicated
altitude that's kind of how aircrafts
are tend to be separated everything else
is kind of nice to know pressure
altitude we talk about it a lot but I
don't think it's really often used in
practice for much actually above it I
shouldn't say that because above 18,000
feet it's used use always said the
altimeter to flight level you know two
to zero instead of 22,000 feet if the
temperature standard pressure altitude
and then see altitude are going to be
the same so that'll be again 15 degrees
at sea level and cooler as you go up the
pressure altitude will also equal the
true altitude so that's the actual
height above sea level again in standard
atmospheric conditions we'll talk about
this in a few a few times in this class
but when it's hot the entire Earth's
atmosphere expands and if we were to
cool the earth down near absolute zero
the atmosphere would contract it might
we might read on our altimeter that we
were at 18,000 feet when we were only
you know an inch above the ground
because the Earth's atmosphere had
shrunk to only two inches in size all
right when you're flying indicated
altitude
there's a expression called high to low
look out below
because if you go from an area where
there's a low high pressure setting to
an area where there's a low pressure
setting you'll inadvertently descend by
a thousand feet if you just follow what
the altimeter is telling you without
resetting the altimeter same issue when
you go from high temperature to low
temperature so I just came back from
Jacksonville Florida and the Cirrus
someone from high temperature and at an
indicated altitude of 3,500 feet I was
actually a bit higher above the earth
and here in cold New England so that's
another thing to be aware of and this
becomes important for instrument flying
and very cold conditions like up in the
Canadian Arctic if you fly indicated
altitudes when it's extremely cold
you'll be closer to the ground and they
budgeted for when they design the
procedure
okay vertical speed if you want to you
know maintain 500 feet per minute
climb rate or descent rate for your
passengers comfort then this instrument
is your friend it does lag so you can't
really use this - all these instruments
are outputs not inputs your inputs as a
pilot are the attitude and the power so
you set a power you set an attitude like
a little bit three degrees nose-up and
then you use these instruments to verify
that you're getting the performance that
you want especially true for the
vertical speed indicator because the
instrument itself has slag in addition
to the lags that come from just the
inertia of the aircraft okay under the
hood it's got this calibrated leak
I don't really
anyway it's not our fancy instrument
than a mechanical engineer should tell
you about all right gyroscopes the main
property is you can use them for an
aircraft instrument because it'll try to
stay where it is relative to space it
has to be corrected in instruments it's
really where gyroscopic precession has
to be considered because think about it
you're going to be showing the pilot
various things on the face of the
instrument so you want to make sure that
it's the the deflections correspond to
what's happening out there in the real
world again this is covered in the
pilots handbook this just tells you
again if you kick if you kick a gyro up
at the top instead of the axis of the
gyroscope rotating downward it's
actually going to the left
that's gyroscopic precession turn
coordinator it has a gyro to tell you
that little airplane if you're doing a
standard rate turn it'll go to this
point here that's a two minute turn
that'll take you two minutes to go 360
degrees and it's a back up to you know a
vacuum powered attitude indicator it
also has this completely separate
function of a little ball in I think
it's in kerosene actually so it's a
little ball and fluid and in a perfectly
coordinated turn you should actually
feel like you're just standing on the
ground at 1g and the ball should stay
right there in the center all right turn
coordinator it can tell you whether
you're slipping skidding or coordinated
so if you're coordinated as I said it's
just like sitting in a chair and not
moving if you're slipping if you have
any trouble visualizing this you can
just reflect on the fact that you have
to step on the ball to fix the problem
so here your airplane is in a right turn
and it's telling you you have to step on
the right rudder and bring the nose more
around to the right in order to be
coordinated so that is a slipping turn
so here's our airplane
we've banked the wings but we've got the
nose still kind of pointed where we used
to be going so it's telling us you need
to kick a little bit of right rudder and
have a coordinated turn skidding is the
other way for some reason we have too
much right rudder in there and we need
to back off of it or hit some left
rudder
and bring it back again this is
something it'll become you eventually
you develop a sort of a feel for it in
the seat of your pants and you'll just
do it naturally and actually modern
aircraft don't have a whole lot of
what's called adverse yaw so if you try
to turn them they're not really going to
get out of coordination to any large
extent all right attitude indicator if
you're either in level flight or on the
ramp this little airplane pointer here
in the middle that little orange thing
is just something that you can rotate up
and down it's basically just a reminder
for you of what attitude will produce
level flight it might be a couple
degrees pitched up or down but you just
set it to whatever it is this is a gyro
that's free to move in two directions
and as it moves it moves this Bank index
I guess on the face of the gyro is what
they're calling it or maybe that just is
the Bank index so it's moving the whole
artificial horizon on the face of the
gyro so it the important thing is it's a
gyro with two gimbals in aerobatic
airplanes this design doesn't work very
well it tends to get damaged by the
extreme maneuvers and g-forces as a
pilot what do you need to know about
this it's worth knowing how to read it
on your in your flight training you'll
do so-called steep turns where you'll
Bank to a 45-degree angle it's mostly a
visual maneuver where you look outside
but the attitude indicator is a good
reference again to see whether the
picture that you've got of a natural
horizon actually does correspond to a
45-degree Bank if you go up I think if
you go beyond 60 degree banks it's time
for your aerobatic airplane and your
parachute
[Music]
that that pointer at the top generally
will be pointed up at the sky however
you're maneuvering we'll see this in a
in a moment here so you can see let's
just pick a a level right turn so over
here you say well that I think at the
top isn't really pointed up at the sky
it's just pointed off to the left but
think about it they're just showing you
the instrument as you would see it in
the cockpit
so because the airplanes turn to the
right that top pointer would actually be
correspond to straight up in this inch
of the sky but as you see it's kind of
the same picture you would get you're
more or less not pitched but you are
banked if you're going up climbing right
bank you see you're just pitched up a
couple degrees there's a little bit more
blue here versus here as an instrument
pilot you'll get very good at seeing
small differences just one or two
degrees a bank or pitch here yeah we're
about to go into the magnetic compass so
let's let's take a break here and we'll
wrap this up after everybody has a pizza
few things to remember about magnetic
compasses and then we're off to Oshkosh
which is going to be more fun the most
important thing is that it only works
when you're straight and level and the
fundamental insight for this is the
compass is a horizontal thing it's only
designed to move horizontally so if you
start tilting it tilting your aircraft
one big part of it a big part of the
problem is the compass tries to still
point itself towards the magnetic north
pole which will cause it to rotate a
little bit it's a little bit hard to
explain without thinking about it and
reading about it in the pilots handbook
but the takeaway is that because it has
inertia and because it's not really
fully free to rotate to point in three
dimensions down to the North Pole you
get all these bizarre errors like if you
turn away from a heading of North it'll
initially show a turn in the opposite
direction and if you accelerate because
of the inertia it'll let C accelerate
north
and yes alright we'll get into that in a
moment even I can't remember just
remember don't look at an unless you're
straight and level the true magnetic
actually the North Pole the magnetic
north pole I heard recently there was
some kind of significant movement anyway
it's moved quite a bit since 1632 as you
see here on this chart because true
north is not equal to magnetic north and
the kind of primary source of direction
that you have in your aircraft is a
magnetic source on the charts you end up
getting these isogonic lines that tell
you how much correction to apply so here
you can see 14 degrees west that tells
you because of East is least in west is
best if we want to fly straight true
north we actually have to steer 0 plus
14 so 0 is the true north of course add
14 and if we see 14 on our compass or
between 10 and 20 on our compass between
1 & 2 I guess it would be indicated then
we're heading true north if you forget
all of this stuff that I'm telling you
which I hope you will because this is a
very tedious area you can cheat so look
at this vor the vor tells you this is
the block island vor this is another
great place to fly so you land there you
walk to the beach you skip out on the
ferry ride this is the best arguments
for general aviation aircraft are almost
always places that are islands and you
can't drive there in your Honda Accord
even if you wanted to so but you see
here the zero magnetic line is not
aligned the chart isn't true north so
there's your true north there's just
your magnetic so you can just see that
the variation here is about 14 degrees C
what it wouldn't even need and you can
also that East is leased West's best
rule you can read arrive it just by
looking at any vor except don't look at
a vor in Florida because that's where
there is no variation but almost any
other view are you
and look at it and see what the rule is
all right magnetic deviation if you have
stuff in the airplane it will cause the
compass to be a little bit inaccurate so
they give you this compass card here
underneath which will give you usually
one or two degree changes at the most
for how you would you know if you want
to fly north magnetic heaven heading you
might actually steer I don't know zero
point steer a course of one or two
degrees if you you know if you bring
stuff into the aircraft that's heavy and
metal or magnetic that can affect your
compass and actually in an aircraft with
heated windshields if you turn on the
heated windshield through anti-icing and
in jets it's kind of standard to fly
with them on all the time the compass
becomes useless the heated windshields
throw it off by 90 degrees all right in
the lowest end airplanes will have a
directional gyro because of all those
compass errors you as a pilot will
basically just every 5 or 10 minutes if
it's a really old and bad DG or maybe
every half hour if it's a decent new one
you'll just look up at the compass when
you're in level and accelerated flight
and you'll reset with this knob here
down the bottom you'll twist that to
align the directional gyro to the
compass so the compass is the authority
but it's only an authority when you're
straight and level okay under the hood
notice that this unlike the attitude
indicator this only has one gimble and
that's really the takeaway for why the
attitude indicators tend to break more
often than these other instruments
because they have to gimbals and they're
just a little more fragile overall
horizontal situation you know everything
and flying they've tried to make it more
idiot-proof and the HSI is a great
example of something that was figured
out I don't know maybe in the 50s or
maybe earlier they said what if we just
take that DG and
we put an indicator on here this is
showing we're trying to go on a heading
of about zero one zero just slightly
north that's this yellow pointer we are
actually going on a heading of about
zero to zero maybe that's because of a
wind correction there's a wind coming
from the right and it also integrates
your line see it shows you with this
course deviation indicator that you're
slightly to the right of the course the
course is a little bit to your left and
actually this person I think is this
pilot is flying an instrument landing
system approach this yellow trapezoid
there on the left and right is showing
you where you are relative as a guide
slope so you're right on the glide slope
so basically all the information that
you need for your flight other than the
attitude is on this single instrument if
you have everything set up correctly the
radios or the GPS you really don't need
to look anywhere but here and at the
attitude indicator it's a pretty nice
idea and this is replicated in all the
glass cockpits all right
technically advanced aircraft here's a
photograph of the latest and greatest
Cirrus sr22 or xx cockpit you have two
big screens ones usually called the PFD
primary flight display ones the MFD the
multifunction display that shows you
maps and weather and traffic this idea
came from the you know big jets from the
80s I guess in 90s it was adopted in the
Cirrus in 2003 pioneered with an MIT
spin-off called Abidine which is a local
company Garmin kind of took things over
and most of the aircraft today come with
Garmin g1000 is a brand name that you
might have heard for a Garmin product
that's pretty popular in some ways
people with older aircraft are almost
better off right now there's this huge
stream of retrofit stuff that's very
innovative more so than the
comprehensive glass panels and usually
for $30,000 or so an older plane can be
brought up to the modern
okay what if things are not going well
at all the ultra lights tend to come
apart in flight certified airplanes
virtually never come apart they're just
so over engineered that you know wings
don't fall off
struts don't fail but the two brothers
the clap Myer brothers from Wisconsin I
believe although the company they
started serious is in Duluth Minnesota
they said look this parachute would give
people a lot of comfort and there are
some situations in which it could be
useful even in a certified airplane so
they added it in the Cirrus and you pull
it and the rocket shoots the parachute
out and you float down it's becoming
more and more popular I thought it was a
weight a payload hogging waste of money
when I bought the Cirrus in 2005 and now
that the engine has 2000 hours out on it
and I'm flying at night I think you know
that's pretty good
it's a pretty good Parrish I mean I
don't even mind the $15,000 that we paid
to have it all repacked the at the 10
year point all right
summary so piston engines they're very
fuel efficient compared to jets at these
power settings they have quirks which
sounds bad you know some wonder one
cylinder might be running rough but you
know it's better than in a jet world
where things aren't perfect the engine
just quits or explodes or something
so turbine engine stall demand go bad
when they go bet but when they do go bad
it's often with no warning
here's your six-pack the altimeter
remember is essentially measuring our
percentage of the atmosphere that you're
above or below compass is full of errors
except on your straight and level and
also that the aircraft manufacturers are
really systems integrators are buying
the engine from somebody they're buying
these instruments like the Garmin g1000
from somebody study pitot-static
failures and the compass errors are on
the exam and they're not they're not
intuitive questions this is another
picture from that air museum and Bradley
they have one of the handful it's not
flying I don't think but it's restored
b-29 bomber and if you want to know why
I get defriended all the time on
Facebook I posted this picture of their
turret computer and I said I found the
original iPad in the museum I was
hashtag not funny all right any
questions or should we going to Oshkosh
we can have questions don't ask about
those brass and knurled things because I
was a math undergrad and EECS grad
student
you